all right let's do this rowboat I love
it
hope I do not remember how to play
mark what oh I didn't know oh wait okay
can you grab me all right pull me in try
it
mark I wish City going backwards bar if
I let go you have a better chance of
good everyone there we go I need
assistance mark no no no no I got okay
you got this
you trust me right yeah I trust you all
right wait come hold me wait come back
get away from the rower step away from
the rower we're doing important stuff oh
[Music]
so I I get it I'm the gondola operator
in your romance movie okay so yeah this
is good for you man no we got to lift it
up and drag it in
alright you drag it you're the worst
don't worry I'm in it you got really
cool it sounds really cool and fast
dude pull harder we go to the back are
you push things away to go you might be
right
oh god is that gonna hurt us I can only
hope all right fine I'll help jeez no
you're off of it so much hey come on
come on we're almost there all right
quick let's get in here no no okay
you're running it Rendon ah never mind I
guess we're good it's fine this money
yes gets away from the shore there can
you you got that you got the control
just a motor doesn't seem to be doing
anything we are running into our old
boat it's fine
crush it keep pushing wake you push it
there we go now we're come there we go
they're off cabinet walk out of it oh my
god hmm yeah there's another bowl right
there you know what since you're all
incompetent I got this what do you got
there the boats out of the way let me
get the boat into the open water look at
that go that way
how do you know because we came from
that way I guess actually
hmm interesting interesting okay
oh you got the boat got too far away
guys Wade you got to drive it back over
Wade drive it back over here we can use
the rowboat to get to it all right good
plan man good plan you will see what
happened on the road or help I can't do
anything all right you're good you're
good time died oh wait there you're all
right cool hey guys have fun what we're
wait no guys no not like this please no
no no pushing me it's not my fault so my
fault it's all my fault try and turn it
around No
[Music]
[Laughter]
mark I'm coming feels actually bad my
god hang on hang on sorry boss blade
come on man don't beat it don't beat it
don't beat it don't be okay good good I
think I can get in there yep yeah we're
good oh not that way sorry I'm gonna be
just
oh god wait I don't know how to drive
this properly why are you guys in a
cloud of smoke I've eats no no the way
the motor aims is not the way it turns
the way the motor not were you aim the
way the motor aims right right it's all
inverse controls I don't know this those
work
full speed ahead we're being a genius
with a rowboat to come save you yes
captain we've been bjv easy climb here
or oh wow kind of one-handed be there
alright Mark's driving mark left
I am trying the left I'm next to you now
there's a big boat can we drive that
boat we absolutely can drive absolute
Louise that's true but I want it to be
sorry I aiming straight for the buoy
there's a boy that way working on it
captain
my ability to turn left is very
limited.i I got this I think I see the
edge of the world the world is flat and
I think be ridiculous don't tell me well
you're one of these disgusting flat
earthers all right all right captain
abandon ship apparently stares you idiot
I can't climb the glass
I got achievement sail away there we go
guys I think we lost the speed boat just
rebound wait oh okay I think you're on
the wrong side there bud all right what
does these do what is these do what a
what a deep question
turning the bow how you doing good you
grab my head or the glass is glass glass
dude all right mark you don't need to
[Laughter]
here man this gives you a feeling of
power I have never felt before
strong yeah wait yeah why don't you
climb the goddamn stairs you peanut
let's get over Bob you get one of these
I'll get the other one oh god they're
both stuck forward hang on wait let's
keep it okay you where are we trying to
go we're trying to dock we I think we
need to dock in there all right
all right so straight forward well
that's it go forward
marks don't got it okay perfect
I think walking forward or you're right
you're right you're right you're right
you're right
all right keep yours on the goddamn
stairs you idiot help me no no no I will
not teamwork guys we are doing teamwork
right yes playing an amazing amount of
teamwork right now docking this huge
boat this is surprisingly incredible I
wish I could go up there and see it but
I guess oh my god yeah we're docked
well done all right I feel like we all
contributed equally they know well mark
yeah your nice little captain yeah you
too co-captain hi 5.05
go away you filthy dock worker get out
of here just warm up the water cannon
thank you there's something here that we
can do are we supposed to be using the
crane to get five oh my god get away
from me I feel you
unshorn behemoth get away I don't I'm
not comfortable I can't hug you in real
life till the quarantines over so I'm
just gonna enjoy it here wait do you
wanna do you want to work together whoa
I got you saved your life do not touch
me I'm literally gonna just disconnect
oh this moves Oh interesting
Oh interesting platform I think are we
supposed to add the boat I think we're
supposed to get stuff off the boat
that's my guess
yeah move those crates so is this all
boat no ahead of us right now is not the
boat we need to go left
get low yeah left wait - we're not in
one of the boat right now we need to
take the stuff off the boat all right
let's see we need to go backwards a
little yeah which one we going for first
I say blink blue maybe whoa - far too
far too far too far all right how do we
hook that oh my god I think we're
centered left right now I'm gonna go I'm
also going to help them do the thing so
one blue one we're doing blue one yeah
is this actually gonna work like I know
this if this works I would be a little
we got two hooks over here it's the
thrill of being a dock workers really
never been more appealing with this
strategy for some reason oh I almost got
this
I've almost got that one okay I know so
close so close so close okay I think
that that's actually hooked yours the
circus mines the only one the song yet
oh my god mark you're a wizard how'd you
do that I am the best alright this one
so you do not touch anything can we get
back so my guys you can raise it up
that's fine all right fair enough fair
enough fair enough
oh sure of our book stuff look at that
we did it Wow amazing holy [ __ ] don't
touch me
God all right drive us drive us home
boys where are we taking it just stack
them oh so we can get up to that
building oh my god that's a big thing
swung it around so we want to build it
so we can climb up I think yeah that's
the objective right so we need one more
on top of the blue one is the blue one
close enough - yeah I think I think so
yeah
do you want me to go over there and give
you a little precision measurements
maybe please don't crush me to death
this would definitely destroy you needs
to go a little bit more right all right
that's good yeah I stopped right away
and it needs to come towards me a bit
skosh in yeah yeah yeah okay now try and
get it down a little bit see if you can
stop it from wibblewobble Aang
easy easy easy a little bit up a little
bit let it settle and then back down oh
my god guys how do we unhook it now oh
we need the orange one because it's half
block we can actually step on that Wow
Hellfires okay oh yeah I know it'll fit
in the middle okay so up yeah and then
toward view guys I'll tell you when to
stop and try and like hit it on the
other ones to stop the swinging oh
that's good wait wait wait lower lower
little wedge right in raise it up just a
touch raise up just a touch not too much
a little bit more
there there there now lower it I think
you're right there trying to get on top
of it it's fine fine fine
it was lined up and then you pushed it
it's not that wasn't me that wasn't me
that wasn't me that was Wade my god come
on we'll close that's not the right way
okay wait wait wait wait oh yeah okay so
now you can try and unhook yeah yeah
yeah
do we want to unhook it right now I mean
we could if I jump over to the platform
while I'm on it
would that autosave us over there
I don't know if it's gonna slot in
between and what benefit would it do
slotting in between anyway nothing Oh
Marc Marc I think we need to I think we
need to just no wait I think you put it
all the way down and let it be all angly
and funky so you can jump up on it let's
unhook it and let's go get the other one
okay
I can't climb up this thing I'm sliding
off it's very slippery at the moment but
I might be able to do it I'm not I got
one I got one into it
he's have to jump I'm not I'm not an
ignoramus like way too incapable of
pretty ignoramus II right now
okay two are unhooked how did you do
that some kind of wizard I know this
side is unhook now uh Wow one of them
rehook hang on unhook you demon you
demon bastard come on you piece of
garbage I don't think this is gonna help
our situation much no no it's fine I
think this is the right plan I think
this is the way to go I think this is
gonna be God you got it we're unhooked
over here working on it wait mine's only
one of mine is unhooked I thought mark
over to your sides
was fixing his own mistakes my own
mistakes I was getting it right in the
first place
measure twice cut once that's my
philosophy all right it's unhooked wait
go go go go go go oh that's a fun idea
[Applause]
for you let go
we'll get it hooked were your hook crew
hang on I need is which arm I'm reaching
with yeah no hang on there you're on
you're on go swallow me daddy we're
gonna set that one down with ours
leading on the way yeah see that's what
I'm saying I was like they shouldn't
seem to think this through very much we
don't have to unhook it we can just put
it over there over where where is it
gonna lay it can hang in the air on the
hook oh you're right you're right you're
right you're right you're right oh yeah
this is not OSHA approved
all right lower us down let's hook this
[ __ ] okay first one almost - and maybe
it is maybe it isn't sort of fashioned
[Music]
Schroedinger the hook who knows this bad
boy is a bridge yeah dude we did it the
right way oh my god my chain is spinning
I don't like that mark I see that it's a
you problem it's not a me problem
[Laughter]
stop it needs to go towards the bridge a
bit I can't see that so the urine give
me
and then down oh boy that's enough stop
okay alright it's perfect it's perfect
in every way
after you Bob after me turn around and
jump on it I get you you gotta let go
buddy
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay I've grabbed both I'm really I'm
really captaining Captain America this
problem you're about to rip my arms out
of my socket no it's fine mark just hold
on it'll be fine Oh Gary yeah
[Music]
you kill them you've definitely killed
him all right I got him what I help
people it's what I do I'm a hero not all
heroes wear capes I did it wrong I did
it wrong easy the goof isn't it you're
easy to goof nice Jesus cried effort
gang good I have to go through that much
trouble okay this is definitely a box I
think I say oh god oh god oh god is that
not right no this is definitely right
okay we go ride this bad boy
how do oh that's a low I'm not jumping
[ __ ] that I'm doing this how do you do
that ex good good luck with that buddy I
[Music]
got this their boxes over here on this
side no I cannot I know oh I flip me die
flipping I'm flipping I'm flipping the
box further on without us guys
help no guys oh oh oh I feel like you
deserve that oh there is a maybe wait
what if we lift the big one oh hey Mark
how's the gun I didn't make it I'm not
gonna tell you the secret but there's a
real easy way to solve this problem no
no you shut up you shut you don't know
what I know which is some amazing stuff
I hit the wrong button
yeah oh not get back up either oh wait
Bob discomfort that's the wave oh right
right right right right okay that makes
sense so what we do with this big red
thing are we supposed to slide this Oh
does it slide oh my god you're right it
slides guys are smarty pants there's
more boxes in here I guess yeah well we
just put him in the next thing and we
use them to I reached under my leg for
some reason Here I am
I'm still alive I know how do we get to
where wait is that Wade go get a
checkpoint ahead just keep going ahead
why so I think I remember this part what
no I'm okay oh dear oh yeah that's about
what we're about to have to do yeah we
have to we're gonna have to grab walls
and balls and all right I do not want
Wade grabbing my balls I'm Wade you grab
my balls I'll grab marks balls all right
behind creep get away from me
I'm grabbing we have to unhook that I
believe nice do we need to hook that on
to this for a moment maybe to do
something I'll remember I started this
part sucking I don't for exactly what
happened oh no I've made a mistake I'm
so close wait why are you standing
looking and not helping Jesus Christ
okay I got it I got it
thanks Wade thank you thank you yeah
it's someone who's not an idiot grab me
okay time time for all of my training
and skill to come into play I'm gonna
get a nice front-row view of this we've
ever come up with we in 2020 the peens
podcast invents the cream pie hey Mark
what's up I found the secret no no I was
right here
man you always got to take things from
me and look mark there's a box up here
do you want this oh man I had it
mark come back gods my secrets oh my my
arm is broken do you need a lift my dude
no no no I want to get I want to get it
under my own power give you no no no I
just got I just got it wait there's
something in this plate there's
something in this pipe yeah right okay
[Music]
yeah okay buddy
we need that mark the side it's fine
it's fine
look I had told reach-around and now I
refuse hey Mark can you help me no but
look I'll lift the box up for you you
grow oh come on man mark we need this
where the hell are we going by the way
oh no I'm over here oh I see yeah we do
need that box we need a boat to get to
the box
guys let's free the boat great you broke
the chain oh god no hang on guys I'm
hopping my own ride you guys okay Marcus
all about not one to be free yeah yeah I
do take your hands off me
that's the one you know homemade my plan
my plan didn't work
wait you'll notice there's a box in the
water that I believe was important to
press the button in the middle oh that's
a waterfall alright you found the
waterfall the swinging along the wall
method oh you so you trying my patented
method II it's terrible
more like delightful oh my god please oh
god what the hell what are you doing
mark I'm trying to climb up a secret way
oh my god now I hate this game just
physics I hate it I hate it very much
where's mark
she's over there dangling on the
distance not anymore
god damn it this game was so stupid oh
look guys just you do your thing I'll do
my thing oh my god it makes oh my god it
makes no sense it's so stupid
alright Bob we gotta go you need to go
left excuse mark can you go to the left
yeah I died the bed the left okay you
got it go go go go go go yes what am i
doing so you need to get around to where
the box is and somehow like push it over
this way okay can you grab the blue
thing you mean sort of okay oh you right
you right you right
just don't like you ain't yourself off
okay
I always join myself ah so sassy with
the pole why can't I get up when I fall
down here we go here we go here we go
what am i doing what am i doing what am
i doing so you gotta climb up there and
then you gotta know oh god no not like
this oh my god
actually if you could get on the boat
and get the box really quickly you'd be
the oh my god I hate this game so much I
hate it so much do it I believe in you
I'm gonna drag the box over to you
underwater it doesn't it does float
hundred bucks bucks okay mark I think
you may have just made the Box respawn
which might make our life a lot easier
there goes a respond do not touch me
right here you guys coming one day all
right so you guys do that same thing you
just did mark go to the left you uh
another box is easily accessible are you
telling way to do it wait boys
incompetent that's true that's true I
mean that's mean wait jump almost scoots
you too far away that's true yeah Jesus
he's a scoundrel Oh someone can actually
hold the boat next to it wait hold the
boat along the thing or okay okay okay
okay it's so heavy why is this heavy why
is it move move mark if you could push
off that wall at all oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god daddy I'm coming
back one day okay let me hear let me I'm
gonna fall I'm gonna grab the boat I'm a
lick of this I'm gonna wait till I get
back up I'm going to grab the wall I'm
gonna push I think it might actually
work better just use your momentum so
like run towards the boat and then put
your arms out and if you stare down
really if you aim down really quickly
you like grab the boat so like right
move forward and then like aim at the
ground and you
wait I think you should provide think
you should try and go help this is not
the met the part of you I intended to
grow well that works why it's not moving
you got this dough you're good your take
take your time it is moving ever so
still ever so slightly actually mark if
you climbed up on the other side and
then jumped back onto the boat okay yeah
no it's fairly okay how do we get it
over to you suppose gonna grab the boat
okay I'm back
okay all right cool my gosh so careful
okay we got a hand off this box we got a
hand off the box I gotta stand up self
okay here we go here we go and guys oh
let it go let it go let it go you
actually use the book to get back over
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah uh-huh
get back on the boat is it over oh god
no oh god no so what is this gondolas
now yellow yeah yeah oh all right whoa
boat boat boat boat boat I'm not getting
up I'm not pulling it back pulling it
back pull it back there we go
wait is off in la-la land okay my stick
is in Oh actually wait wait a mess left
okay all right we're pushing off
this way sorry
Oh God Oh stick I think it stick is
better just like pushing off a thing is
probably a lot all right there we go
push push good push I'm gonna streamline
the stick here a little bit all right no
no pushes I'm falling wait wait we're
here we're here mark oh this look sorry
I gotta get up I fell God get up get up
get there oh my god I just hold the
stick hold the stick my hand is but my
hand is behind my back I can't my hand
is behind my back come on stick tape
stick tape stick why is my hand behind
my back no one will ever know why is it
who knows you get one more get a push
now just jump just jump it just jump it
there goes my hand is high this seemed
like the place we're supposed to go up
here right sure okay what you doing
nothing what are you doing making
progress
you uh you cream in some pies over
hate my approach on this thing okay I
don't know where this is gonna go but
here I go
no god oh my god oh my god are you
kidding me oh my god are you [ __ ]
kidding me hey well am i alive what the
Frick you're doing and I'm dying right
it's I'm not here okay so you do run and
jump but for some reason my run and jump
went drunk I tell you that thing is
messed up running and jumping on that oh
it's slanted that's why
I'm just going to take the easy way out
alright you do the [ __ ] to get here
that's not impressive time for my
technique whoo oh yeah use that and you
pull the boat over here really I am
making so much progress with my patented
technique hey what's up guys buddy man
taking this it's like taking the
elevator when you should be taking the
stairs for your health
I beat you I beat you I beat you I be
you guys over there we're just goofing
no no no no I'm gonna throw rocks at you
[ __ ] go argh oh wait wait wait nope
we're supposed to load it up so it sinks
a little I get that we loaded up with
these rocks probably need both hands on
there there we go it's going on no not
yet we'll go out sorry actually going
now okay so then I'm gonna I'm gonna get
up I'm gonna take a rock out
god damn it are you kidding me whoa
we'll get a checkpoint for use my
technique where are we going wait we're
kind of stuck right now all right we
needed me didn't you a-holes made the
stick maybe you unbelievable a hole
we're trying to get a checkpoint for you
no the other way yeah
we have jammed this absolutely the worst
way all right action Oh God there I go
oh oh this is lovely
oh my tail Oh just works perfectly oh
did you guys get checkpoint or what oh
no you did not oh wait I can get up no
don't get off no not then right why
right exactly then oh wait no wait why
have you [ __ ] me wait why did you do
this to me nice oh my god okay I'll get
off so you can actually make it up wait
you know I can't help you if you can't
there you go yes did you make it I'm so
close did you do it Bob yo oh man I was
so close to pole vaulting oh my god I'm
just a little oh my god Allah that was
good
you can make it I keep hitting my feet
on the ground I'm on oh my god why that
was the one unbelievable believable
dick you unfathomable douche we you
beyond dick
dick that was the worst thing you've
ever done is it ruined I can't believe
you I can't believe you that was by far
the worst thing you've ever done I was
right there that was the swing I don't
think I'll ever be able to forgive you
for that
I really don't that's like you did a
real dick move their way oh my god Bob I
wish you could have seen it I wish you
some rocks yeah yeah yeah yeah I guess
some rocks I'll do some rocks shoes and
throw you in the Cincinnati oh yes I see
that
oh the Ohio River sorry is it going yeah
it's going good meet us on the other
side feel free to help Wade I can't wake
up fast oh [ __ ] we're drowning good this
works better if there's just one of us
so I think I can jump out of here and be
safe to hear ya so you'll float you can
jump up up there now guys I could reload
the checkpoint so I can come back okay
man so I want to get onto this chain
thing yeah but you know two people
really screw it up because it can unhook
from
clasp apparently there you go so now I
do this whatever that does oh can you
actually can you raise it up so draw I
could drop off up there no I didn't make
it that's fine it's fine it's fine
spider it's too low I'm gonna scooch it
up and I'll catch you there's any
problem all right that's what you're
here for always on my side always here
to help well okay my god you need to go
up a little bit I think no it's fine I
got this this will be the what this next
one here
[Music]
yeah but how do we get it to go it stays
in whichever direction you pull it so
once you turn it on it just goes okay
you want me to pull it in you go sure
yeah okay here we go hey guys do you
come back for me nope oh yeah baby
[Applause]
sorry guys do you guys forgive me for
doing this I'm about to do you do not do
it no fine don't do it we literally
can't turn it around if we wanted to do
so there's three I know I gotta get to
you somehow no just hold on who let us
touch the top one one
point two-five
uh-huh uh-huh
forget ahead account zero I thought you
guys might have got to the checkpoint
[Music]
okay that's good that was what a good
podcast we had guys no no it's okay I'll
fix this thank you everybody so much for
stopped by this week tune in next
Tuesday when we find a new member
no guys love three beans in a pod we
will have the brand-new brand-new member
with us he or she will be so talented so
funny and so thoughtful
guys come on let's go all the qualities
we've been missing we could do this
together you'll get all the latest news
and updates scammy news world news for
the vents and less baggage bob streams
over at facebook.com slash my skirm go
give him the follow give him a like
watch the stream good guy good guy that
Bob good guy good guy great streamer
great streamer always rely on him
facebook.com slash mu why is ke erm
we'll see you next week that was the
funniest [ __ ] that's ever happened
apparently
[Laughter]
[Music]
you